se acerca la hora de la verdad para
ecuador los ciudadanos se elegirán el
domingo entre un banquero conservador y
un economista de izquierda en una
segunda vuelta presidencial que convoca
a más de 13 millones de votantes a las
urnas al pie del río guayas el candidato
conservador guillermo lasso pidió que su
mensaje fluya a todo ecuador al tiempo
que abogó por la unidad nacional para
superar la crisis en el país andino el
próximo domingo es posible iniciar una
nueva etapa de progreso en la que todos
estamos vivir mejor
en sus manos tendrán el instrumento más
poderoso que existe para conseguir que
se cumplan nuestros sueños representante
de la alianza centroderechista guillermo
lasso promete estrechar la cooperación
con eeuu e impulsar el libre comercio
será la tercera la vencida lazo ha dicho
que este será su último intento por
llegar al palacio de carondelet tras
haber perdido contra rafael correa- en
2013 y contra lenin moreno en 2017 su
rival el candidato progresista andrés
araus hizo lo propio con un mitin en
quitó en el que apareció su mentor el ex
mandatario rafael correa en un vídeo
enviado desde bélgica el candidato de 36
años de edad dijo que una de sus tareas
si llega al gobierno será la de juntar a
las fuerzas sociales y productivas del
país para dar solución a la crisis
económica y sanitaria a todo el ecuador
convocamos a este gran bloque historia
para poder lograr la unidad de nuestro
pueblo y poder salir de estas terribles
crisis las últimas encuestas daban una
paridad casi absoluta entre los dos
candidatos con una ligera meta al
economista araus sin embargo al cierre
de campaña siguen dependiendo del voto
de un 25 por ciento de indecisos entre
ellos una parte de la comunidad indígena
que ha sido instada al voto nulo